[Música]
en los últimos días el presidente de
perú pedro castillo anunció la
iniciativa de un referendo para dar una
salida al océano pacífico a bolivia la
noticia polémica fue luego corregida por
la cancillería peruana que descartó
cualquier posibilidad de ceder
territorio peruano y en cambio aclaró
que su respaldo a la demanda marítima de
bolivia se ciñe simplemente a dar
facilidades de movilizar carga a través
del sureño puerto de ilo con nuestro
segundo invitado del día vamos al
análisis de esta noticia nos acompaña
omar khadr o roldán abogado
constitucionalista y profesor de derecho
constitucional de la pontificia
universidad católica de perú muchas
gracias a usted y de donde nace esta
iniciativa de castillo es necesaria
no es completamente
innecesaria parte de un error
la posibilidad de que perú de que la
salida del mar a bolivia pase por perú
está descartada desde por lo menos 1929
todo lo que se haya habido es en
negociaciones entre bolivia y chile para
que pudiera esta salida
realizarse por arica este actual
territorio chileno pero como fue el
territorio peruano
antes de la guerra del pacífico de 1879
eso requiere el consentimiento de perú
pero no hay ninguna posibilidad de que
en las negociaciones que han habido
repito desde 1929 de que la salida al
mar de bolivia pase por perú y en
segundo lugar el cualquier acuerdo
respecto a límites respecto a
establecimiento de fronteras
pasa por la aprobación del congreso es
decir cuando el presidente castillo dice
que apoyó una salida al mar a bolt para
bolivia a lo único que podría estar
refiriéndose es que apoyó el reclamo de
hbo de chile bolivia frente a chile para
salir por el territorio chileno pero de
ninguna manera podría esto significar
que es una salida por territorio peruano
más aún cuando según el artículo 56 de
la constitución peruana cualquier
acuerdo respecto al territorio peruano
para dar una salida al mar a bolivia o
para cualquier otro efecto de soberanía
requiere aprobación del congreso bueno
sobre eso le quería preguntar porque
pese a la aclaración que hizo la
cancillería quedó resonando la
declaración de castillo para cnn en la
que defendió además que un acceso al mar
es un derecho de bolivia usted que cree
no lo que ocurre como en bolivia perdió
en la guerra del pacifico perú perdió la
provincia de tarapacá y la provincia de
arica y bolivia perdió su salida al mar
desde ese punto de vista hay un
hay un derecho que muchos presidentes
peruanos han reconocido a bolivia a
salir a la mar pero no por territorio
peruano entonces esto como es
consecuencia de un acuerdo internacional
entre chile y bolivia posterior a la
guerra del pacifico en el cual
bolivia perdió militarmente la salida
del mar entonces y esto pasa por una
negociación que deben realizar chile y
bolivia y el y la línea de perú ha sido
respaldar
que bolivia tenga acceso acceso al mar
pero no por territorio peruano bueno y
en su opinión es que tan factible es que
se lleve a cabo esta propuesta de
referéndum
perdón no le escuché le preguntó qué tan
factible ve usted que se realice esta
propuesta de referendo no no tiene no
tiene lugar en el derecho peruano eso es
una es una declaración
impertinente
del presidente invirtiendo y en realidad
trascendente porque no existe la
posibilidad de que se someta a
referéndum una un apoyo a la
posición de bolivia respecto a su salida
por el territorio chileno y mucho menos
respecto a una hipotética
salida por el territorio de perú que
está descartada repito desde hace mucho
tiempo no no no es no es parte de lo que
maneja el perú como posibilidad de
negociación y del apoyo que le da al
derecho de salida al mar a bolivia no es
por territorio peruano entonces es un
referente a un referéndum de ninguna
manera es aplicable en el perú para
asuntos de este tipo bueno y teniendo en
cuenta la aclaración que hizo la
cancillería y hablando ya de cambios en
la política el movimiento de mercancías
hacia el mar desde bolivia usted cree
que hacen falta cambios o mejoras en
esta política comercial actual que
existe entre perú y bolivia
si eso eso pasa por acuerdos con
acuerdos que perú se le ve con bolivia
actualmente en el puerto de ilo hay una
franja de cinco kilómetros de largo y
uno de ancho de ancho por el cual
bolt bolivia tiene un derecho de uso por
99 años dependerá de los países desde
los gobiernos de perú de bolivia llegar
a acuerdos relativos a materia comercial
pero lo que debe estar claro es que
ninguno de estos puede comprender
soberanía es cesión de soberanía
cualquier cuestión relativa a salida al
mar por territorio peruano en
requeriría aprobación del congreso por
lo tanto el congreso peruano es quien
tiene en sus manos esa decisión pero no
es no no no se no se maneja en el perú
ni siquiera ha sido reclamada por olivia
el reclamo de bolivia es salida al mar
por por territorio territorio que hoy
hay de chile y que en su oportunidad
fue de este fue de fue de oli de una
parte y de perú en la otra
en su propia nave refiero antes de la
guerra del pacífico de 1879 claro en esa
medida la cancillería fue muy clara en
que no está dispuesto el país
a renunciar a su soberanía sino a
mejorar los acuerdos comerciales y por
eso también quería preguntarle pues en
su visión de país en qué medida podría
beneficiarse eventualmente el perú si se
garantizarán mejores accesos dentro de
la política establecida para que el
comercio boliviano pueda llegar más
fácilmente o más efectivamente
hacia el mar y ahí tomar otros destinos
si todo acuerdo comercial creo que es
beneficioso pero
dependerá dependerá de las políticas
que se manejen del dependerá de los
criterios con los cuales se hagan esos
acuerdos comerciales de las finalidades
pero lo principal es que no conllevan
una sesión de soberanía
y qué reacciones ha habido le quiero
preguntar ahora pues al interior del
país porque esta es una noticia
internacional que llega a toda américa
latina que causó muchísima sorpresa
cuando salió este titular de cnn pues
porque se pregunta uno por qué un país
se decidiría por voluntad propia su
soberanía en una disputa que ni siquiera
le pertenece como usted nos ha venido
explicando cuáles han sido las
reacciones dentro del gobierno o las
críticas suscitadas hacia pedro castillo
lo que ocurrió en él pero hay una crisis
política muy muy grande en este momento
la elección de pedro castillo fue
desconocida hasta casi una semana de que
me juramenté por la oposición que
predomina en el congreso y entonces el
congreso a partir de esta declaración
desafortunada
ha realizado una magnificación y
pretendiendo acusar de traición a la
patria al presidente castillo cuando el
presidente que ha sido no tiene ninguna
posibilidad de realizar sesión de
territorial alguna porque la
constitución se lo prohíbe la
constitución le da la atribución de
aprobar los tratados de límites al
congreso entonces el congreso peruano
tendría que estar despreocupado del
asunto porque el congreso nunca
aprobaría una sesión 12 de soberanía de
este territorio plano sin embargo por
razones políticas han magnificado y
distorsionado esta declaración si
ustedes si usted escucha la entrevista
en ningún momento el presidente de perú
habla de ceder territorio peruano sino
de apoyar la posición de bolivia lo que
parece que no le explica en términos
claros y utiliza una figura impertinente
eso sí que es el tema de la cuestión del
referéndum y eso está fuera de lugar
para cualquier cuestión relativa a
límites oa
sesión territorial por acuerdo
internacional todo acuerdo internacional
pasa por el congreso y el congreso en
lugar de afirmar que esto es imposible
de realizar porque la constitución no
prohíbe alentado una crítica a la al
desacierto
de la declaración del presidente
castillo sobre el referéndum como si él
estuviera anunciando una sesión que la
constitución peruana se lo prohíbe
entonces creo que
si ha habido un uso político
distorsionado de esta declaración
simplemente con finalidades de ganar un
espacio
por parte del congreso en el en
perjuicio del presidente pero con una
repercusión internacional lamentable
porque en realidad no hay ninguna
posibilidad de que perú se da sobre
territorio soberano a bolivia pues viene
le agradezco mucho por cedernos este
espacio para aclarar todas las dudas que
surgieron a partir de esas declaraciones
de pedro castillo es omar khadr o roldán
abogado constitucionalista y profesor de
derecho constitucional de la pontificia
universidad católica del perú muchísimas
gracias señor cairo